we understand there's a war happening
but we also have our lives and our lives
are very important to us yeah and what's
the most important vacations yeah
vacation comedy jokes and akash was just
in california yup and uh on a podcast
run yup and during the war how was that
yo i invaded california and uh they
welcomed me with open arms wow yeah yeah
no anything you hear otherwise it's
propaganda it's spin
uh no this is my first time doing a run
on so many of those podcasts and dude it
was the best yeah yeah the whole la
podcasting's thriving it's great they're
all hanging out having fun it's great uh
we did fight on the kid which is dope i
never really got to hang out with
brendan and uh brian we had a blast and
shipping yeah they're crazy uh
tiger belly bobby lee i had never met
we'd never met each other he's the best
son that's the best
i haven't had fun on anybody else's
podcast like that nobody's more fun on
the planet yeah that was the most fun
incredible even post rehab the best yeah
uh we did i did tiger two or what's the
trash tuesdays that's those girls came
on here said they were gonna try to
kidnap you
why's that yeah maybe they said they
weren't gonna give you back oh warren
all right fair well they gave me back
pretty quickly but uh
you know the best thing was you go to i
started they killed it over here by the
way yeah they're great
they're great uh the best thing is i
started in l.a and i got no love from
anywhere like i go to the comedy store
and wait for the [ __ ] open mics and i
never really went back there in headline
because you know you just you don't get
the opportunity and then to do the whole
podcast run and sell out all the shows
like irvine was 500 seats and i remember
walking out and seeing every seat full
legitimately kev my camera guy kevin was
filming me walking on stage and my head
like cocked back like god damn every
seat is full i've never seen it like
that oxnard the love was crazy people
were like standing up when i got on
stage oh that's funny and uh it was just
it was just a dope yeah we're blessed
man this is a beautiful it's a beautiful
time good [ __ ] yeah dude la's great i
can't wait till i move out there i'm
just really excited about all the things
we're doing yeah you think it's la you
think we'll move to l.a somewhere warm
is all i'm saying i'm with you on that
i'm done i know there are bigger
problems in the world but right now no
no no no there's not yo you know what's
so true is like maybe that's why putin's
doing it because he's freezing because
he's just freezing yeah exactly yeah
he's like what's a little bit warmer
yeah
get me closer to the black seat no he's
got crimea he's got the southernmost
part of ukraine how warm is crimea
though yeah i guess that's pointless
yeah he
you're just angrier if you're cold
that's why this guy came in in a mood he
didn't get the l.a trip yeah the vitamin
d you want the other hand you got
you got the light of the whole world in
you
[Laughter]
got a second cigar it's so funny
[Laughter]
so
what else
it was just a fun man again it was just
cool to go back there and like not worry
about meetings with some [ __ ] agent
who you know could get you on some dumb
ass show you probably don't want to be
on it was just cool to go there sell
tickets do comedy hang out with comics
and i i always heard the la scene was
like dead because rogan left they're
doing great dude they're doing great
over there they're doing their shows
they're selling the tickets they're
making their money and then they just
they they all got multiple podcasts and
they're all just they seem to be having
a blast yeah and it was cool to see the
like feel the love as opposed to going
there's like some young kid who nobody
knows and nobody cares about that's fun
on this side yeah
fun on this side success is good yeah
that's what we were saying is uh where
do we go
do we leave uh new york
i'm so ready yeah winter [ __ ] sucks
here dude yeah it works dude it still
works bro it's the worst and i'm like
yeah i don't know every time i walk in
the [ __ ] streets and i got my stupid
[ __ ] shoulders up around my ears even
when it's like 43 it's so [ __ ] windy
you're like what it's it's 32 or
whatever it's freezing it's freezing
yeah i'm out if you don't have to live
here in the winter you don't
there's nobody that lives here in the
winter because they want to
they live here in the winter because
they have to
but
we have to get to a point where we don't
have to right and then where would that
be la is not all it's chalked up to be
traffic
that's true traffic traffic sucks so we
can write our own schedule they've got
to come to us
okay work around traffic influencers
those are they're not i'm not the
biggest fan of l.a yeah i i was happier
i'm i'm happier when i'm in miami than i
am when i'm ill i'm fine well i loved
miami yeah i like my lap miami my only
concern about miami is raising a
daughter there
oh yeah yeah we go to the suburb go to
fort lauderdale yeah jupiter florida
jupiter no we're not going to jupiter
florida i don't know about it but it
seems fun
too far north
you guys want to make another one of
this right here bro yeah he's from
orlando i'm from pensacola yeah from the
basement mark will like going there but
are we really basing our futures off of
what you have popping out okay where do
you want to go dove no you have to i
know you you'll know i'll do miami if i
can get my whole family out of miami no
no no no the the thing about the miami
thing with the kids is like
i felt
like you you kind of get wrapped up into
the culture that you exist in right and
it's like the value system
of miami
on one
side i love i love this idea of like be
with your family and like love one
another and like party and like that
latin vibe of like let's just have a
great [ __ ] time yeah smile enjoy life
that is the [ __ ] yeah there's another
part of miami which is like people who
have never gotten money
and then they just got a lot of money
and they have to let everybody know that
they got a lot of money so the value
system skews a little bit you're like
how do i show off the money now new york
has
money show-offs but there's something
about new york where like style is value
now i'm not saying that that is more or
less corny but
you could get [ __ ] just being like cool
looking mm-hmm you could you could be
homeless getting [ __ ] like west elm
caleb was [ __ ] everything in new york
that's not happening in miami there's no
west ham caleb in miami right so it's
like now there might be but it's a guy
driving a lamborghini he's got [ __ ]
leased and he's going to spend his
entire money he's living with his
parents yeah so the little thing is the
front so my i do have a little bit of a
fear and maybe this is early like what
if my daughter
comes up in this is that going to be her
value system now my question is why
would you have a daughter
that's kind of suss i'll be honest i
want to have a daughter that'd be like i
want to have a dog why would you why not
just have six boys that's what i'm going
to do
just cause you're the gayest guy in the
room doesn't mean all your sperm is male
1
all my homies bro all the boys in my
ball bag that's the guest yeah yeah yeah
100 what are you talking about i want
some [ __ ] in my balls
bro yeah yeah that's crazy they're all
fighting over the balayages
oh man bro i wouldn't have gay gays if
my kids were gay they'd be tough gays
really yeah and how do you make them
that they just be around me
the toughest gay on the block yeah bro
i'm freddie mercury right now look at me
i got my wife beat i feel like al don't
want a daughter
you guys don't worry about that at all
like the culture you're going to raise
your kids in yeah like
yeah
when i was in
because you have access to it all yes to
like i don't know and maybe maybe other
people don't feel this way but like
i don't know i feel like you're so close
to wealth and you're so close to poverty
you're forced to accept all of it and
understand that these things can exist
in one lifetime there is definitely
positives to growing up in new york but
i also think it's a little crazy to have
that much access to everything yeah yeah
it's a lot a lot of people it's a lie
you don't get a childhood that is
insulated in any way yeah so new york
kids are mad stuck up that [ __ ] was
always annoying
yeah y'all would come to down to florida
go to college and be like oh yeah i'm
from new york yeah really yeah yeah and
we get mad [ __ ] after we see that [ __ ]
so it's like and it works
man
the only thing worse than that
in new york and then they move and then
you go where are you from they're all
from new york they go really but they're
like well i moved out of you know
florida they come over here yeah yeah
exactly new york is the america of
america
yeah yeah you know that's [ __ ]
you know like america just goes like
we're the best country in the world yeah
like there's no real metrics
but we believe our propaganda and it
works
and you don't believe our propaganda
you know that you should work so tight
they're not from here we did nothing to
be born here at all but we feel we're
better than y'all because of it yeah no
i didn't know crazy i did that i leave
and as a comic you're like nah i'm in
new york like what are you what's your
little cute city about exactly what that
should happen i go back home and i go i
live in new york what are you talking
about
what are you talking about
swing that damn tell me this tell me
somebody tried to tell you about good
food in orlando when you go back home
and you're like get out of my son [ __ ]
it bro i see someone standing in a
crosswalk i just go by
yeah yeah yeah what are you waiting for
yeah you let the government tell you
when you can cross the street
on mass and get vaccinated yeah yeah
that's true we are [ __ ]
new yorkers are cucks about certain [ __ ]
and we think that we're badasses about
others about everything 100
what is there to be badass about
jaywalking no actually actually
we
you live in florida it's a [ __ ] six
lane highway you're gonna jaywalk that
you walk across the highway everything's
highways yeah
you got a nice bridge over the highway
you don't got to walk across that's what
i'm saying i did in orlando i was doing
a show and i tried to walk
where does the war happen are you
talking about orlando
right
you